a moon as a arbitrary enshrine there I
realize as I write as X also on myhnegon
in material country of swaps K I am
ditch-digger
as far as drugs in schlotz Co it's
pretty good we are the green bounce and
we have American dream I find good job
in Peak effect Sarah I make this vow 100
years or family everything changed
[Music]
it's been 100 years the pickle brine
preserved him perfectly it to old music
the world has changed everyone I know is
gold you were able to track down the
great-grandson where are they they
passed away it was a car crash it will
tell me everything of their deaths how
their bodies died their faces as a life
left we will bond over our pain I
[Music]
understand why you're a religious person
but I not how do you grieve for death
parents do okay idea is that the whole
business that's a very stupid idea you
have no wife no job no friends no job
you need I'm fine
it will become success Wow very pungent
hmm yeah that's straight from the devil
you will finally make their parents back
don't talk about my parents you never
met them the hearts of the entire world
I'm probably not best-case scenario for
the family's become an old company we
have seen I'm sure this is aged well if
man does not throw poncho it is because
these men secretly put the or don't
something bad he cured polio red clay
organic Jonas Salk was give you
he was eat this her father no as David
Bowie
give me some mother no that's also David
Bowie that whole posters David Bowie
[Music]
you